in the ground now
get on the ground get on the ground on
the ground now on the ground on the
ground I'ma tell you get on the ground
get on the ground on the ground on the
fucking ground now illegal on the ground
on the ground on the ground
get on the ground get on the ground
hey get on the ground get on the ground
on the ground
on your back then
grab his hand we'll help you out we'll
tell you we'll tell you
me too
close
[Applause]
I'm gonna tears you out here
already I'm sorry about that we got one
in custody hey
that's how you know come on
please
and I really haven't even done nothing
though
hey man we're sorry
calm down
before you go back to the car
490 forever
come on College everything's gonna be
legit all got nothing illegal on me
everything legit
my bad man I want to take this off a
little bit right it's all good bro I
just want to call my people because I
ain't doing this they can't put my stuff
back on please yeah baby come pull
myself down babe I'm okay
what you need me to do call my Mom hello
everybody
I ain't doing nothing what's playing
everything man
what's your name
I'm scared as hell okay
all right what's your name
because I ain't doing nothing
I messed on the team I called you
everything now I just pulled up on this
is hot out on me of course I'm scared
I'm scared as hell okay we'll talk about
it man no come record me she can record
because it's so illegal
they said pull up on me hop out on me
hey here's a tattoo yep okay
[Applause]
I'm pretty fast
come on
you all right you okay yeah any injuries
any you injured
are you injured
this is
[Music]
no I don't know
all right turn around
stop
stop stop stop
stop okay
foreign
let go of your hands
officer I'm good okay
stop moving up
thank you
bring this up bring this up
hey Keep Your Hands Up
hey anybody got less lethal yep
[Applause]
hey what
oh my God
hey come back over here this come back
over here to the car
hey anybody got a sleep before I got no
not the four okay slowly keep walking
towards us keep your hands up
hey who's got commands I don't have a
voice hey keep moving slowly with your
hands raise above your head put your
hands down as far out in front of you as
you can
in front of you on the ground
put your hands on the ground in front of
you
all the way down on the ground
on the ground
backwards
crawl backwards
all the way out
are we all ready
see that what I've been here for hours
yeah it happens
yeah bad weather gotta do something
right I don't know what we're gonna
blame it on but watch out yeah
unfortunately it's their policy you just
can't be that intoxicated when you fly
in a plane okay I'm not that and
constipated we need you to go to the
terminal
okay Chelsea just just go to the
terminal okay
uh I'll I'll help see her out you guys
are good oh man that thing kind of goes
fast
I think I'm faster but
I have a bike pursuing a suitcase in a
minute
it's gonna be crazy
I know I know I know totally normal
right
Chelsea you gotta get off the doors are
gonna close
Chelsea can you do me a favor
can you roll with me to the to the main
terminal you can't hang out here it's a
secured area
I will just leave you alone
yeah follow me follow me Chelsea we'll
roll out together
Chelsea I'll race you
Chelsea let's just let's just roll our
little wheels to the other side of TSA
okay
because this is a secured area I gotta
have you on the other side to say and
then I promise you I will leave you
alone
[Applause]
I have been nothing
of polite and professional with you
Chelsea Chelsea look at me Chelsea look
look at me Chelsea look at me
thank you
Chelsea if this continues you will be
arrested
for disorder
Chelsea please
don't just spit at me
Chelsea you are under arrest for
transparent back now Chelsea on arrested
do not resist do not resist
stop spitting do not speak
one time
is she hitting her head no no
stop stop stop Chelsea stop
Chelsea you need to stop this nonsense
you need you need to improve your
behavior
Chelsea stop this just stand up
Chelsea stand up
all right reverse reverse
we're gonna go on the car nice and easy
all right
slide in
watch your feet
Travis can you please put down the ax
put down the ax
put it down back up back up away from
the edge
you're gonna get changed
stop stop put your hands out on your
stomach on your stomach on your stomach
I got him
I got him yep just wait hey go MP I'm on
duty
I have water I'm supposed to resist
you will get shot if you move you're
going to you're going to put your hands
behind your back you're gonna be
executed hands behind your back
do it now he's good he's good he's good
I'm doing what's intelligent
there you go you're gonna get shot got
blasted mk-12 get your guns feed a
hoverless release me
you're all right Travis you put your
hands behind your back
keep them there
you realize your whole department is
going to be prosecuted
231 now
show your fucking mouth no it's okay you
are you're gonna call Nato
I have all the lights
one
you will be punished
only reason I draw my weapon six eight
Richland can you page UMass
just uh 10 43 one taser deployed
unsuccessful
yes
he's running South on sextonville South
on sectionville
I'll get a squad
[Music]
you will get shot if you move you're
going to you're going to put your hands
behind your back you're going to be
executed hey that's behind your back
do it now he's good he's good he's good
I'm doing what's intelligent
no no
you're gonna get stuck
all right Travis just put your hands
around your back
on there
realize your whole department is going
to be prosecuted for 231 now you need to
shut your fucking mouth no it's okay you
are you're gonna call Nato
I have all the law back to me you're all
actually good fighter president
you're all answering to China president
you will be punished
only reason I dropped my weapon is
because I know you're all gonna die
you got gloves on you it goes you let me
go grab something please
wow
Trader free
let's finish right in the truck
yeah
so it's okay you didn't check it in you
should have done that
the beautiful of Duty 2381 violations
we're good you're a terrorist for the
service lesson oh yeah father are you
tires for the service weapon then you're
gonna be executed the refusal of Duty at
the maritime NATO level will have you
executing your own bottles they're
calling every load Madison is on their
way up here too by the way to clean
house up here
of then for God personnel
Snowden breaches
with an FBI field office in Russia at
the time enforcing Russian law and your
president
you're all going down
NATO's on their way the Chinese have
joined NATO and they're in the country
now to reinforce us they're arresting
their officials for speaking out against
the U.S
you're all outnumbered you're out manned
you're terrorist and they'll be letting
me out momentarily in order to be
executed by me where's the hatchet yep
just leave them there
photograph them
there you go if I don't think I'm I can
outperform them
prostitutions
Department agents here branch
come get me NATO
I know you can hear me from satellite
camp
got you all on video site
we're here
oh I didn't know I dropped my phone okay
what's your exact location hands put
your hands in the air stay right there
stay right there
keep your hands in the air
turn around turn around and back towards
me
back I'm walking back keep walking back
keep walking back keep walking back keep
walking back get on your knees get on
your knees
stay right there
I think it's gonna be 10.
80.
keep your mouth shut
up you're ready
[Music]
one more in the car
over the pastor door
open the passenger door
driver passenger
hello it's okay come here it's okay
squares
[Music]
[Applause]
hey stop stop stop put your hands up
stop
on the ground
hands out
right now
thank you
yep
great job
open it
give me a sec
it's a shotgun
foreign